This name kept coming up.
Who is this guy that I keep hearing about?
He wasn't there, but he was right there.
The record business, Hollywood,
civil rights.
Anything that had to do with
the rights of people.
That told you everything you
needed to know about him.
He was fearless, man.
Absolutely fearless.
We needed to know him because
he was the gatekeeper.
He knew everyone.
Everybody!
Oh man, he was too fly.
One after another.
He became a powerhouse.
There's the power that needs
the spotlight,
but there's also the power
behind the scenes.
The guy's a rock, in every way.
Agent, manager.
Orchestrator.
This mysterious figure everybody respected.
You only find one of those people.
I'm like, how was the guy doing it?
Sometimes I say to myself,
"How in the f*** did I get
into all of this?"
I don't let nothing get in my way
about anything that I want to do.
Clarence was an African American
man in Hollywood,
defying what Hollywood was
supposed to be.
Black people are going to
move forward.
No matter what business he was in,
he never wavered from his purpose.
Seeing that things were fair.
He said, "Would you like any help...
...putting MCA into
the black music business."
I said, "Yes!"
He said, "Well thats good 'cause...
...I'm gonna tell you what to do anyway."
I would hear about people,
that were in very serious situations
when it came to life.
And they would say the only
person that can help you with this,
is Clarence Avant.
Clarence is the bridge,
from a time where
there was no opportunity,
to a time where doors
began to open.
He understands the bigger
that we are together,
the bigger we will be
as a culture.
Henry Aaron would not be Henry Aaron
if not for Clarence Avant.
The message that I
recieved from Clarence was
just think about those kids
thats looking up to me.
The person that's
responsible for your transition,
that's the key to changing your life.
He became that mentor for us all.
Became that godfather.
Remember the first time
someone ever said you're the godfather?
Well people call me that,
people can call me anything.
People have called me a son-of-a-bitch.
So what?